nous réfléchissons juste à cette chose, faites-moi
savoir si je vais trop vite pour vous pourquoi
quelqu'un tuerait-il un livreur de pizza
et à quel point un homme armé sait qui il
allait tuer cela n'a aucun sens
c'est très bien tu as  votre discours
prêt pour le surintendant il y a eu un
meurtre dans ma circonscription, nous avons entendu des
coups de feu c'est un meurtre musulman, pouvons-
nous simplement dire que c'était un être humain, il a été
abattu dans une rue britannique, ils
essaient de tout nous prendre c'est une
façon de  la vie qu'ils veulent détruire nous
pensons que votre frère a été tué
délibérément parce qu'il savait quelque chose
Sam Spencer mes cinq nous pensons qu'il y a une
dimension de sécurité nationale ils veulent
vos informations mais ils ne veulent pas
donner les leurs ils ne
peuvent  à tout le monde et on contrôle
Personne ne croit plus aux institutions
et c'est exactement pour les raisons que tu
m'en donnes aucune ça se résume à des pili j'ai
besoin de noms on va devoir t'échanger
et moi
t'as un kit de jeu ce sont des gens
vit m  votre père avait une opinion intéressante,
il a dit que si vous aimiez une institution
sans affaires, cela signifiait que vous l'aviez mangé
si vous étiez amer l'institution en avait
une
on nous offre une chance de vous arranger
quelque chose